loool et bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france alors cet
officier à l'inde depuis hier soir
alassane ouattara est candidat à sa
succession pour la prochaine élection
pourquoi avoir annoncé aussi tardivement
voilà sa réélection en tout cas sa
candidature pour la prochaine élection
bonjour et merci pour l'occasion que
vous nous accordez de nous de nous
prononcer si vous aurez effectivement
tous les tuant sur le coup c'est un choc
ou non parce que l'état est il
admissible pour nous en côte d'ivoire de
voir un président de la république
annoncé sa candidature aux comptes des
partis politiques on peut dire que ce
nom une nonne l adage qui dit n'est
jamais trop tard mais et alassane
ouattara est bien encore là de montrer
ce qu on y restait au la constitution de
vote d'eads et adéquat de boire son
monde dames ou même où la patrie
ivoirienne en général comment cette
candidature a été accueilli dans le pays
hier après l'annnonce de ouattara sa
candidature c'est on va être juste on va
être juste
c'était de la manipulation et
l'opposition n'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment pas satisfaite de cette
décision parce que le pays a été long
mois éprouvée et cette troisième
candidature vient encore de mettre en
avant le manque de temps de parole
le monde de parole du président alassane
qui a promis à ses fers qu'il n'allait
pas se présenter qu'à promis à la nation
voire à bien il faudrait juste un mandat
et après il a eu un deuxième mandat et
de la halle est encore fort c'est pas
des mandats c'est une c'est clair que ça
donne le pays parce qu'on on anticipe
déjà tu sais qu'il va se préparer vous
même vous êtes témoin du fait que le
aujourd'hui n'est pas sur la liste
électorale portées par le leader et tout
ça ça crée des remue ménage donc c'est
cette position c'est une décision qui
est vraiment malvenu en côte d'ivoire où
les hivers dans l'ensemble des ivoiriens
son principal opposant laurent gbagbo
est élu est absent de la liste des
candidats que pensez vous de ce retrait
c'est un retrait abusive et arbitraire
depuis que le président alain s'est
réveillé en côte d'ivoire comme
président nous avons assisté à une
chasse à l'homme qui ne dit pas son nom
et là de le savoir que le président
bédié est ballot qui est l ancien
président sans être jugés et condamnés
en côte d'ivoire à part que ce soit
peut-être par contumace a été levée sur
les violences électorales et un abus
grave et l abus grave et ça doit être le
baril inscrire on estime que au condamné
il faut déjà être jugé et pointe jugée
et il faut déjà avoir fait la prison
après le jugement et avoir d'avoir quant
au casier judiciaire
il faudrait il faudrait déjà être
emprisonné avant d'avoir le casier
judiciaire mais vouloir d'abord on
constate il était content a condamné par
contumace et en même temps un casier
judiciaire qui sanctionne son
emprisonnement et c'était justifie son
action sur la liste électorale
nous disons que la machine judiciaire
est mal utilisée ici en côte d'ivoire et
c'est clairement un déni de nombre de
non droit et là nous dénonçons fortement
et fermement manifestations violentes
ont eu lieu hier justement à ce sujet
qui a d'ailleurs entraîné des
affrontements entre partisans de laurent
gbagbo et les forces de l'ordre
une protestation qui met en lumière les
tensions socio politique dans le pays
selon vous oui effectivement et ça
commence par là c'est ce que nous avons
commencé par dit cette candidature mais
pas mettre en mal la cohésion sociale
alassane dramane ouattara n'a pas pu
réconcilier les ivoiriens
la preuve en est la preuve en est qu'il
n'a pas pu aussi à vaisselle ses
collaborateurs avec lesquels il a pris
le pouvoir en 2010 aujourd'hui alassane
dramane ouattara se rend coupable de
tout ce qui va venir en côte d'ivoire de
tous ces kilos va hors crise en côte
d'ivoire
aujourd'hui c'est on célèbre le 60e
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la
côte d'ivoire on est à trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle comment
s'annonce ce scrutin c'est dommage j'ai
eu hier j'ai eu les larmes aux yeux
aujourd'hui je sais pas si je pourrai
sortie ni organiser quoi que ce soit on
a l'impression que la côte d'ivoire
naples a pas eu de réponse aujourd'hui
avec alassane ouattara où les 60 m à 60
ans d'anniversaire de l'indépendance qui
devait marquer un sou d'union nationale
possède un registre enregistreurs
désolation parce que nous n'avons pas de
drapeau à part les promesses qui ont mis
les drapeaux sur leurs bords du nous
n'avons pas de drapeaux aux commandes y
parle dans le compte de l'état de
côte-d'ivoire et ça c'est une grave
violation de notre patrie nous ne
sentons pas que c'est la fac de
l'indépendance et ça c'est une première
de savoir que nous n'avons pas accès à
des fêtes joyeuses ou fêter nos 60
condamnées c c'est déplorable noël où
les merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de l'union des femmes du
parti démocrate de la côte d'ivoire de
l'agrégation du mal